now i know it's warm out there uh the
met officer just confirmed
that it is the hottest august
day since 2003 so hottest august day in
17 years
temperatures widely above 30 degrees in
the southeast heathrow and kew gardens
have hit
36.4 degrees which makes it the hottest
august day
since 2003 um and sun seekers are being
urged to avoid
busy beaches um it's expected to be
hotter while it has it is already hotter
than some of europe's
top holiday destinations including ibiza
and tenerife
um we sent our hottest reporter in
rasheed to canvas sans in east sussex
forest
indie have you got an ice cream in the
last hour did you join that queue
not yet but that queue will be joined
very shortly because i've seen plenty of
people with ice creams this afternoon
uh jane so i definitely have to join the
party and get one but there is a party
atmosphere
on the beach here in camber sands a lot
of people have flocked to the beach
thousands and thousands of people on the
seafront enjoying themselves this is
the busiest day of camber sands beach so
far this year according
to the rnli lifeguards here on site we
were just chatting to
the supervisor here who's telling me
that it is incredibly busy for them but
they are prepared
and they're very satisfied with the way
people
have been behaving here you can see it
is absolutely packed a lot of people
have flocked here to camber sands beach
we
just came through one of the entrances
actually where the car parks here
are absolutely ram jane they're really
really full
a lot of people have come down by car
it's a spot which is quite difficult to
get to
by public transport so a lot of people
using the cars to get here but that has
caused a bit of controversy a lot of
the residents local people really
unhappy with the amount of people that
have managed to come down and they're
actually worried
that with all these people down here it
could uh affect them in terms of kovid
19 and a surge
in the weeks to come it's quite
difficult to social distance if i am
being brutally honest
a lot of people probably are trying and
it is in the back of their minds
especially with all the people that
we've spoken to
but it is quite difficult because
obviously there are so many people
coming
because it is so hot let's go try and
chat to some of them see you fanning
away
already are you enjoying the heat
absolutely it's wonderful
one of the hottest days of the year they
um determine that it's a hottest day of
the year so we thought we'd come out and
just have a
a good time at camper sands today why
did you decide to come out has it been
difficult throughout the coronavirus
crisis not being able to get out and
enjoy yourself
absolutely obviously the lockdown has
meant that we've not been able to come
out and
be able to enjoy you know attractions
like this so
the fact that opens up we thought you
know take advantage of it and
just enjoy the weather and enjoy the um
the company and it is hot isn't it
you're keeping yourself hydrated
it's extremely hot making sure we're
keeping ourselves very hydrated
not advertising extremely hydrated yeah
drinks here right enjoy yourselves stay
safe it is an incredibly hot day here
the last time i checked was around
33 degrees celsius as you said jane a
lot of a lot hotter than
countries like spain and italy and
that's why a lot of people have come to
the beach because they can't get away
to these countries because of covert 19
restrictions so instead
they've decided to take the car come to
the south coast and enjoy
camber sands incredibly busy but also it
does come
with those notices from the council here
saying actually try and stay social
distance stay away
if you can go to some of the quieter
beaches this is one of the busy
uh hot spots now uh in the south of
england and it will stay busy throughout
this weekend as
those temperatures stay hygiene